president biden is facing increasing
criticism tonight for what some critics
say is clearly a broken promise about
getting americans and thousands of
afghans who helped america out of
afghanistan white house correspondent
peter ducey looks at the controversy
tonight
afghanistan policy has not played out as
advertised if there's american citizens
left we're going to stay to get them all
out turns out all out meant 9 out of 10.
90
of americans in afghanistan who wanted
to leave were able to leave so even
though the administration initially
claimed it's irresponsible to say
americans are stranded they are not the
pentagon later clarified we have
americans that get stranded in countries
all the time then there are those who
helped the us in wartime how about our
afghan allies does the commitment hold
for them as well
the commitment holds to get everyone out
that in fact we can get out and everyone
should come out that didn't happen
either are there more people who want to
leave afghanistan absolutely early on
the president was confident in his plan
the likelihood there's going to be
the taliban overrunning everything and
owning the whole country is highly
unlikely but they did in just 11 days
afghanistan political leaders gave up
and fled the country the afghan military
collapsed
sometime without
trying to fight still the president
claims he felt global support i have
seen no question of our credibility from
our allies around the world yet
criticism was heard including in the
british parliament where one mp took
major issue with the u.s president
criticizing the afghan army to see their
commander-in-chief
call into question the courage of men i
fought with
to claim that they ran
it's shameful
however this president stands by the way
he ordered the withdrawal i gave my word
with all of my heart i believe this is
the right decision
a wise decision
and the best decision for america as a
candidate president biden once claimed
that if he won other countries would
have reason to trust and respect the
word of an american president again but
so far on foreign policy his word and
the way things have gone have been
different brett peter do you see in the
white house briefing room peter thanks
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else